[Music]
and welcome back to today's
inspirational episode of the careful
boys where today we have a water
drinking silent mic in the building stay
hydrated kids let's go B stay
hydrated good message careful boy shirts
available now go get it link below
something why are you so short dude why
so large bro I eat my
protein there's something about chairs
you know like obviously they have a
mechanism to rais and lower but when
they are up they are more comfortable am
I on a bad
date how old are you why are you saying
all this how old are you did you run out
of stuff to talk about cuz he asked
about my damn chair he asked I never
said about your chair I just said why
are you so [__] big because I was
raised my seat up cuz it's more comfy
when there's some bounce to it okay here
we go we invested a lot of good money
into these These are good chairs though
they were good chairs they're like
$1,000 they were good chairs honestly
there's a nice little bounce no honestly
they're expensive if you're at the very
bottom this is like buying a Toshiba the
state-ofthe-art in 2013 and like we
spent good money on that thing I know
what I have here it's a state-ofthe-art
it's it does 1080i if you're at the
bottom it's not comfy but you raise it
up a little bit it's comfy as [__] it's
comfy as [__] it is a lot of money
what's the what's the
question you want to get on with it huh
all right it's a lot of money what is a
quote
that speaks to you and why do you like
it mother
[__] I got I saved this [__] on my
Instagram I got tons oh [__] go ahead
Steve wait me first yeah me you're po
you say you are pointing you said I got
you oh [__] get me I feel we got to pull
from memory though cuz if it really
speaks to you I think that means you
memorized it get his ass not you WR or
no okay Abraham Lincoln said every
whatever you are hey whatever you are be
a good one and I think it applies to
being gay mine says just don't be gay
mine says what do you open a fortune
cookie what's one you got I know Bart's
got a bunch do I Church Hill said every
day you make progress every step be
fruitful yet there will uh lay before
you an Ever ascending ever improving
path and this so far from discouraging
only adds to the joy and glory of the
client and that that's a good one is the
one that I love the most that's a long
one because it's all about yes you will
struggle and that is a beautiful part of
the process and it is a necessary part
of the process you should be excited
about the struggle you should wake up
every day and embrace the fire of the
struggle I do and that is why we are
going to do it again let's go baby
nothing good came
easy that's how I wake up baby that's
how I wake up baby come on wo Stacks
filled one month to make it here we go
in the meantime to get busy I stay
busy I think Churchill's other one I
think it's Church Hill a violent attack
today is better than a well planned
attack tomorrow
y there's another there's another Church
Hill there's another Church Hill I don't
like Arabs that's another Church Hill
also relevant he didn't like Arabs I
don't like Arabs I he says I straight up
don't like Arabs I straight up straight
up no cap he said yeah no you're like a
old dad uh stoicism [__] like cuz those
quotes are going everywhere I do like uh
Marcus aelius has uh the best revenge
Mar realiz is an old dad no he's a stoic
okay got it and old dads are into
stoicism on the internet go uh the best
revenge is to be unlike your enemy
that's something I I try to live by
that's a nice one yeah that's something
I try I have my own quotes that are
better than other people's we got to
process one at a time so that I can whip
them out dude I love quotes RI Flair
says to be the man you got to beat
the yeah is he involved with the project
he has to be such a tragedy but no I've
been trying to pressure I've been trying
to pressure the wo team I even talked to
the vice president ecosystems for my
podcast they they don't have Ric Flair
involved it's an outrate but we should
I'll DM him right now I'll should have
shot yeah you could reach him on Cameo
pretty easily $5 all let's get a classic
zoke quote all right I like the jack
off I like
turtles hey he hey I like
birds okay okay okay here's what all
right people rather feel right than to
be right that's my quote [__] I like
that I like that I'm not weird you're
weird that was a joke quote do these
look weird that was from today was this
morning but of course this isn't in
order so and how do you live your life
according to that one I don't live it I
just observe It You observe your life no
cuz I think people um they're more
concerned about being validated rather
than actually understanding objective
truth to a lot of things and re like how
they perceive CE reality how they think
like some people are so caught up in
being validated of their truth or
whatever they feel like it's to feed
their ego like but they'll make the same
mistakes and maybe they'll have patterns
that are
self-sabotaging um and they keep
reacting the way that they do because
for them it's more important to feed
that ego and stay right than to actually
correct their behavior to be
successful or even like look right too
right they rather look right yeah so
that's what I mean so it's like in
majority of folks I think they rather
feel right than be right and win or a
thirst from a lot of people want to be
accepted and guess what dude you're not
going to be accepted by everybody [__]
off like it's not going to happen like
you need to you need to be comfortable
that some people won't accept you Amen
brother and dig in on who the [__] you
are I really think that but that's like
a me quote so who cares that's a Steve
Green original that's a Steve Green I
think of one that I tell myself it's
like if you want to be a loser you start
tomorrow I think that's a good one cuz I
think for me for me my thing is like
I'll just put it off I'll procrastinate
procrastinate so I have to tell myself
like if you want to be a piece of [__]
if you want to be a sack of [__] do it
tomorrow so it forces me to like now
could done you say that to yourself
every day doesn't that mean you never
reach tomorrow you're always a loser
yeah wait what Prince said Prince said
Prince said if you remove your rib you
can suck your own dick yeah and that's
true that's true and that's more about
like your it's like about the The Ether
yeah isn't that an urban legend
no no no that's true uh if uh you
shouldn't throw stones if you got a
glass jaw you should watch your mouth or
something 50 Cent watch your [__]
mouth cuz I'll break your face yeah cuz
I'll break your face there's one that I
heard it was like uh life is just a
series of five minute tasks or something
like that and I think it's like that's
good if you procrastinate cuz I always I
catch myself procrastinating too or
sometimes like there's a task right in
front of you and you think it's going to
take an hour so you just put it off
later you it's too hard you don't have
that right now but then you start having
this pile up of [__] and then finally at
the end of the week you're like [__] I
got a [__] ton of [__] and then when you
do it you're like dude that was 5
minutes that was 5 minutes that was 5
minutes that was 5 minutes and then so
when I started to think about things
that way I'm like oh [__] like if it
just happens now I just take care of it
and it's done I don't have to waste my
band it feels better when you finish and
then you don't have anxiety about it but
you have to take a lot of showers
first I have so much anxiety I'd never
been like that yeah I just get it done
[__] crush me I won't be able to
sleep one of my favorite quotes from a
kid was welcome to the United States of
bir and it was ta
K United States a butt love that but
damn United States a butt yeah great
quote D I like how he looked at the
ceiling while he says it too okay
everybody everybody instead of just
throwing [__] out throw out your
favorite I love what Steve he [__]
memorized something he laid it out
that's obviously something that was deep
and and very mean to him what is
something that really stood out or quote
that maybe you would even entertain
[__] tattooing on your body since
you're such an ink Fest now well I want
to get a quotes on me dude what the [__]
n dude I'm not going to get a qu that's
too much real estate I'll probably get a
dragon on me or
something fish this is literally a quote
yeah true everyone a dinosaur quote that
I there's a quote that I kind of live by
but the problem is it's not a quote
because I never memorized it but this is
the general sense
okay try your best on what you think is
worth forward I'll look it up and I'll
help you out okay it's something along
the lines of
um if you if it makes you uncomfortable
then you must do it yeah yeah I like
that I forgot what the actual like I
don't like committing
crimes I don't like butt what I like
yeah so what I like guess I got to do it
what I like about it is because the
things that like you either make the
most excuses of or things that you
aren't um that like kind of rub you the
wrong way like you that's where the most
growth happens is when you actually do
it and you figure out oh [__] I can do
it yeah the little like uh be get
comfortable being uncomfortable yeah
yeah so even though like I'm extremely
introverted when we first did JK stuff I
was like [__] it man I just go [__]
speak in public and just get out and
meet people and do meet and greets cuz I
that's where like growth is going to
happen do a lot of people obviously
social media era change stuff but do a
lot of people like dig into quotes cuz
maybe it was just a sports thing growing
up like my basketball coach and even
when I coach I coached basketball for
like 6 years and even strength and
conditioning like uh we we kind of have
themes and and stuff to tie the team
together and so we'd like base it on a
quote in the season or you'd bring a
quote before a big game to make some
kids think about [__] is that normal is
that only sport there's no better
motivator what do you fear most yeah
like Coach Carter [__] yeah kind of no
really though yeah like my coach my
coach right now uh well he's the
greatest fear that's what it is yeah
yeah is to be in my my my coach right
now is the the most winningest coach in
California history high school
basketball and so like he just has a lot
of really ties kind of like Coach Carter
stuff like real team building stuff and
so we always like quotes have always
been a part of what I do in a way yeah
that's why I Whi mine out and Anthony
said I guess I didn't memorize them long
enough for mine weren't as long as yours
so mine didn't count your was kind of a
long one yeah means a lot to me but the
but the Deion Sanders what he's doing
with the Colorado Buffalo I you guys so
cool talk about quotes talk about like a
motivator right he's a walking he's a
walking bar you didn't make me so you
can't break me oh and he he has worked
these kids so hard with the quotes with
the motivation stuff that he I don't
know if you guys saw this locker room
speech that he gave it was so great and
then he was talking about he said all he
had to do was say he says you know we
aren't coming and then all the kids got
emotional and they're like we're here
you [__] like that that g me chills y I
love it that's all he had to say and
that's all he had to say cont is so good
says we aren't coming I'd start being
like I am you start laughing wow I'm
coming hard I'm coming hard to make it
uh uh real popular the look good feel
good play good that's di that's Dion in
the 9s honestly one of the most
inspirational humans on the
earth I love that sh that's really cool
I I tend to just uh listen to quotes and
then translate it into my own mind and
then it probably turns into a different
quote but there's this one where it was
like whether you tell yourself you can
turn into peanut butter in my
mou I'll do it myself I do it better
there's this one that's like whether you
tell yourself whether you say you can or
you can't they're both right yeah yeah I
don't know is it what that what did that
turn into though yeah that's the real
one okay that's what I thought I thought
I morphed the real one into that how
turned it into his I made that quote
up yeah that's the real one but I don't
even know who the originator was it's
jge D original was it Marcus Aurelius I
don't know who the real one there's some
like movie things that hit me like what
uh King Kong ain't got [__] on me that's
a statement nothing he just nothing yeah
so denz Denzel and Remember the Titans
says uh I don't scratch my head unless
it itches I Don't Dance unless I hear
music we will not be intimidated that's
an amazing one it only really
matters what I'm talking bzel fan all
right okay dude he's my favorite actor
period period hands down you smoke that
[__] another one is the very end of
Harry Potter for all my Harry Potter
heads out there and Harry's like dead
spoiler alert he's dead or something
right and he says uh wardian liosa no
that's not what he says he says um and I
might butcher this a little bit but but
it's so good to me at least he says
something like um is this happening or
is this all in my head and Dumbledore
says Harry even if it is in your head
that doesn't mean it's not
real does that make you want to watch
Harry Potter dude in Flight is he
shooting basketballs you're watching
Flight with Denzel Wasing right he the
drunk pilot drunk pilot he he gets he
got he has the the stter the planes
going down and he's like he's like you
you got to son right and she's like yeah
and he's like he's like say I love you
Trevor like that one [__] as as are
[__] hdden trees yeah he's like
what's your what's your son's name she's
like Trevor she's he's like say I love
you Trevor that [__] is verse that thing
oh that's when he became my favorite
actor oh really not even before that not
like a training day I I didn't even see
training day until after that oh
Training Day training day and Remember
the Titans Will Remember the Titans for
top movie that final scene of man on
fire when he's walking oh my God when
he's going across the bridge since we're
losing memory
quotes I'll tell you something that I
like myself okay check this out
[__] education is the ability to
listen to almost anything without losing
your temper or your self-confidence
Robert Frost that's wow cousin of Jack
Frost hey shout out big shout right yeah
shout out Jack Frost he's not a he's not
a a snowman though oh God just the yeah
that's what I thought too it needs it
one of my favorite military quotes is uh
never never what the [__] I just had my
break never uh that happens that
happens never forget Never Surrender
something like that never all right I
got one I got one some of mine are more
like stories you hear going back to the
sport that's hard uh I think it's uh
1988 1986 allstar game I don't know
where we're at three-point competition
Larry Bird hops in the locker room and
said which one of y'all [__]
coming in
second hey what's up Larry Bird
underrated trash time if Larry Bird lost
that's the best sh it been great if he
didn't hurt his back dude all time goat
hey what about none of these are quotes
guys they're call outs wait wait wait I
got one wait let me [__] I'm sorry he
was in he was waiting in
line [__] good guy okay master ugu
from Kung Fu Panda oh I'm a fan do or do
not there is no no
try that's good ain't that Yoda
Simplicity D redid it no he didn't he
did that kind ofur yeah but he kind of
Yoda likee you know Jason he's a good
character he basically is Yoda in that
movie yeah I got it don't make decisions
when going
uphill so a lot of people they they have
a plan they have a plan right yeah they
have a plan I'm going to do this I'm
going to [__] stick have a diet I'm
going to stick to for 30 days day 15 oh
you you know what but I got a friend in
town or should I have a cheat meal or
it's my wedding I'm hungry don't make
decisions when going uphill complete the
climb and then when you're at the top
looking down now how do I readjust
that's cool don't ever make thought was
whack now I get it I thought it was like
yo when everything's crashing and
burning that's when you start making
decision when it's tough when it's tough
don't plan because you're in a bad state
of mind you know you're like I I have
something to piggy back off of that by
Mr n okay n when we are tired we are
attacked by ideas we conquered long ago
oh have you ever been anxiety woken up
in the middle of the night and then
you're like ah and then you're like I'm
having a high school flashback
[__] when I had that moment I
was talking [__] to that bully but then
I didn't have the right words to tell
him and it's like I already got over
that took care of that one but why am I
reliving that trauma
why parallel to Barts I think it's Mike
Tyson everyone's got a plan so they get
punched in the mouth yep oh that's a
good one keep your plan under adversity
under fatigue if you can keep that you
probably win semi mature perpendicular
parallel to that one which is actually
my favorite parallel yeah my favorite
quote of all time this is for real my
favorite
quote life will give you whatever
experience is necessary for the
evolution of your
Consciousness how do you know this how
do you know this is the experience you
need because it's the experience you're
having at this moment
you're to I didn't know that but you
know the Layman oh I know totally yeah I
read it uh the Layman is like you're
gonna live the same lesson until you
learn it kind of deal that's so true I
think you're gonna like this one but go
it's not Epicurious it's epit epitus you
know this guy course hepatitis epidemis
I Got That vaccine elephantitis yeah
epic Titus okay he who laughs at himself
never runs out of things to laugh at
love it that's the good one that's the
JK dude
serious I like that you can't take
yourself too serious [__] down you're
talking to the kiss stealing Wheeling
deing limousine riding jet flying son of
a gun and I'm having a hard time keeping
these alligators down now give me three
claps and Rick flu and Ric Flair woo
love that but I'm not doing the clap do
you like
that yeah you want to dig into quotes
bro you dig into some Old Stone Cold
Steve Austin or the
rock
what
all that [__] is crazy the rant uh Stone
Cold went on a rant about um like going
to a bar the night before you going to a
bar you going to drink beer I had
another beer you're going to have
whiskey we were going to work out I
started doing push-ups what chinups what
barbell curls then we did some back I
did some ropes and then I took his ass
outside I took his ass inside and then I
give him a hell
yeah he's so good undefeated bro no
one's better than him really is was
better he is unbelievable he is the
modern day electric that's you know this
is a great prompt this is I learned a
lot from all you guys and to end this in
a very in a very JK style I like the
jack
off jacking off is one of the best
Pleasures on this part voler we all love
Vol and he said the most important
decision you make is to be in a good
mood comedy baby it's really good very
true other my second favorite quote of
all time and anony Lee show me the
proof
911 talking oh that's what yeah that's 9
that's the reference okay go go go go
go